now there was raucous Applause at the
White House today now and it wasn't for
Joe's handling of covid or Russia or the
economy it was because the real star was
back in town Barack Obama
please welcome President Barack Obama
[Applause]
now if you thought Biden looked
tentative and kind of feeble when he's
on stage by himself it is really bad
when he's on the same stage with Obama
Biden almost a appeared to kind of
disappear into the background thank you
Vice President Biden
vice president
that was a joke
I heard some changes have been made
apparently Secret Service agents have to
wear aviator glasses now
the Navy Mass has been replaced by
Baskin Robbins
and there's there's a cat running around
well for a moment you did kind of forget
that Biden was the president
or that is just 38 now in the polls and
that the Democrats are set to get
shellacked in the midterms
for a moment a brief moment it was like
old home week Joe Biden and I did a lot
together
he has dedicated his life to the
proposition that there's something
worthy about public service it is good
to be
good to be my name is Joe Biden I'm
Barack Obama's vice president
Obama is just the consummate politician
he does have that uncanny ability to
make the most mundane things sound
important
and to sound confident in himself even
when things are falling apart now Biden
he has the opposite problem and today he
seemed even less steady and self-assured
now make no mistake this wasn't an event
to celebrate 12 years of Obamacare 12 is
that some special anniversary it was an
event to try to resuscitate Joe Biden
chalk that one up as another swing and a
miss by the way the problem with Biden
of course isn't his comms team it's not
his PR it's not that he doesn't have
Obama's star power and he doesn't the
problem with Biden is his policies
and none of Obama's smooth talk changes
the reality of what's happened to his
party because Americans see really
clearly now what the Democrats
priorities are like number one open
borders it's absolutely no question in
my mind that Biden sees it as his
mission to allow in as many illegals
into the country as possible over the
next three years maybe as many as 10 or
15 million when all is said and done
second priority sex talk with kids
the Florida legislation is the tip of
the iceberg the Biden White House is
aligning itself now with the most
radical elements on the issue and when
they're pressed on it and boy are they
pressed on it they just fall back on
generalities
at what age does the White House think
that students should be taught about
sexual orientation and gender identity
we have spoken to uh the don't say gay
bill in the past what we think it's a
reflection of is politicians in Florida
propagating misinformed hateful policies
that do absolutely nothing to address uh
the real issues that was a simple
question that she couldn't or didn't
want to answer and it's just like judge
Jackson when she pretended that she
couldn't Define what a woman is
in both cases both women knew the right
answer
but they also knew that if they said the
truth they'd be destroyed by the left
I wonder sake is heading for the hills
before the midterms I can't blame her
third priority January 6th and
Prosecuting Trump
now they worry obviously that if Trump
wins they can't beat him
so by 2024 they think they need to knock
him out of contention
he took an oath to protect and defend
the Constitution of the United States
and he failed to do that for many hours
while the capital was under attack he
violated his own oath of office by
inciting mob violence it was the most
dangerous moment for our democracy in a
century
now they see the Attorney General as
their new insurance policy now according
to the New York Times Biden said he
privately wanted Mr Garland to act less
like a ponderous judge and more like a
prosecutor willing to take decisive
action over January 6.
but wait a second I have a question I
thought Biden didn't he insist that he
would never pressure the doj
I told you I would not tell the justice
department what position to take or not
to I'd leave that to two entities one
the January 6th committee into the
justice department that's their judgment
not mine oh just having to leak out
though that he wants Garland to be more
like a prosecutor okay Joe
now they are just obsessed with Trump
and when they should be obsessed with
addressing problems like the ones they
created inflation for instance
fourth priority the war on cars
if you're not driving a plug-in you're
going to be paying through the nose
forever if the Democrats have their way
let's face it
and high gas prices they're not a
consequence of bad policy high gas
prices are the policy he canceled
Keystone suspended new federal oil and
gas leases he raised fees for federal
drilling on land ordered all government
vehicles to be zero admission
etc etc now gas was 238 per gallon when
Joe Biden took office now it is four
dollars and 17 cents per gallon that's a
75 percent increase
number five
racial resentment now have Democrats
just given up on fixing the cities and
the public schools they wreck both and
now there's a mass Exodus out of both
crime and underperformance will do that
and of course cities struggle to recruit
and retain police because of comments
like these do you believe there is
systemic racism in law enforcement
absolutely but it's not just in law
enforcement it's across the board
it's in housing it's an education it's
in everything we do
it's real it's genuine it's serious
these certain inflammatory comets are
typical on college campuses
but touting the diversity equity and
inclusion racket only divides us further
sixth priority destroying women's sports
Democrats are all in for the trans
agenda which goes far beyond tolerance
to demands that you must accept and
celebrate those choices
and so by supporting biological men
competing on girls and women's sports
teams the Democrats have awakened the
mom vote because I'll tell you what
the daughters of mothers across the
country they didn't train to play
softball just to be displaced by some
six foot two guy who whiffed on the
men's baseball team or practiced
swimming for years just to be bumped
from a spot on the All-American team by
someone who swam with the men just two
years ago
I watched them get out and cry with
their coaches and their parents because
of the emotional and psychological
turmoil that is taking on these women we
grow up being told the world isn't fair
life isn't fair and Sport provides one
of the very few opportunities that we
rely upon and that is being taken away
from them all of a sudden
the mom vote take it to the bank now
this all adds up to a platform of
midterm misery for the Democrats and
they don't care they're just double
Downing on it doubling down on it every
day and Tuesday's brief Obama Biden
reunion it's not going to do anything to
turn things around for them it only
reinforced what we already know
that Biden doesn't know what on Earth
he's doing or at times where he even is
[Music]
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else